hi welcome to the video regularly
playing Resident Evil 3 demo and I am
super excited for this game because I
freaking love Resident Evil 2 I mean it
was terrifying the game mechanics had
changed so much from the originals and I
think that's what was really intriguing
as well I loved the fact that they kind
of switched up what you knew about
first-person shooters one it wasn't the
first person shooters about shooters
where headshots or everything headshots
not everything in that game mm-hmm so
anyway we're just gonna start the game
story can't wait to meet nemesis the new
flag is spreading at terrifying rate
embedding itself in corpses were
generally the streets Jose encountered
immense difficulties in attempt escape
the skin city
it captain it's fine young lady could
use our help
Carlos you didn't even think the worst
fine young lady your name she is an
elite operative of our LPT special
tactics and Rescue Service
her name is something Valentine its Jill
nice to meet you Jill
I am you BCS platoon leader Michael
Victor my team was sent here to rescue
civilians right how's that going for you
this city is completely cut off isolated
most of the hundred thousand civilians
will wind up dead
correction Undead my platoon has
suffered serious losses my platoon is
seven series lasted manage so you can
thank your corporate overlords for that
yes well we are doing all we can if we
can get this subway train moving we can
evacuate some survivors well why do you
think my men cannot do this alone I know
it's a very heavy heavy train carriage
all right I mean am i finding the
generator you've always gotta find this
generate here in horror games not yours
wait it's cool I want the same thing
Thank You Jill all right super cop
go look at that massive hair contact I
know what a radio is that's it first
things first
she's half I get you geared up head up
this trial you'll find supplies there
all right so the girl that I should come
to me perfection with who did the 3d
models characters she's been doing those
of hair stuff and she's got an Instagram
account now I'll try and find out what
it is and share it with you but her hair
stuff looks great hair always baffles me
with 3d models it's so hard to get it
right
on the battlefield if you run out of
ammo your guns about as useful as a wet
fart I mean people don't like wet farts
run away from you I guess maybe not
zombies want to stay out alive out there
then get these basic four meters jump
out shotgun shotgun
I love the shotgun what the started with
soda Celtic just seeing that wait what
what guns if I go ever got mad hmm I've
only got a handgun I've got a knife
that's useful it's always useful if you
get caught I guess
why okay I thought it's telling me to
run
that's nemesis what Easter Egg April the
third hell yeah telling us to buy the
game I will I will don't worry I've
already got it wait no I haven't I have
I need to buy the game all the posters
are everything okay okay I'll buy it
I'll buy it
Jesus in the gray of the morning all
cannibal murders a frantic cornered
telephoned the our PD to report an
assault and man described this diss
disabled disheveled like a vagrant was
attacking a passerby north of the
Ladin's
Museum of Art the responding officers
discovered the mutilated corpse of a
woman by some dumpsters nearby dozens of
bite marks covered her body and she'd
been dismembered just suggesting she'd
been eaten but they had known incident
of its kind
so whodunit who's been munching on man
steak we here at News comet have a
gnawing feeling that the so-called
cannibal disease patients Spencer
Memorial have been providing free
treatment for since August why not be
settling for just the cafeteria food our
reporters have infiltrated Spencer
Memorial ask the tough questions and
come back with horror stories that will
make your stomach Royall
turn the page with Anna scoop I can't
turn the page forties
working on it so what's the plan bowling
copy that let's do this fast
you don't look wimpy just wait until the
scary part comes I mean maybe I won't be
but I usually am if you've seen any of
my other horror Let's Plays I want I
want a shotgun
oh that's really nice fit by the way how
do a nice fit woohoo
how do we know Feeny fee cuz I'm a lay
have to shoot you you have to shoot you
I want a nice I want a nice fit time
oh here we go oh we can't nice yes I can
perfect thank you I'm learning I'm
learning cool like that old one was
raccoon you know it's it's weird man
thing there's no place in the uvcs for
pipsqueaks you crawl back to face every
single time to get scratched up you want
somebody to kiss your boo-boo go
someplace else here in the big leagues
we make summer meds so get these recipes
memorized high potency mixture I
remember this one oh cool you can get it
with three green perhaps didn't know
that yes I need a first name spray have
you got one here's me seeing as you're
talking about it
okay we have ourselves a little storage
box but I'm just gonna have a little
look around first
Thomas its dog okay how do we jump out
in gum power mix more handgun bullets
right yeah there you go
should we store this bunch yeah store it
for later
[Music]
gotta get that tree moving
huh here he comes
baby that headshot baby yeah yeah yeah
which one I cap oh you think I didn't
see you there
I guess I go this way hover crate down
the bloody corridor always love this hmm
oh that's cool that's cool
it's amazing of the original game I
swear there was like a scene just like
this but it was all fixed camera angles
and stuff can you guys can you guys
still hear me okay just check in I know
you can when I scream but can I am
Crouch crouch I feel like I should be
crouching I don't think I can Crouch oh
great no here we go oh god here they all
come
oh [ __ ] I miss oh [ __ ] this bucket why
did I do that why don't ya oh my god is
that a I don't know I'm not using the
next controller
[ __ ] a duck wait I'm using a PlayStation
controller
why is everything think it's Xbox right
oh I need to find me a green earth
what's that noise
oh it's him look at him he's massive
they're gonna they're gonna come through
there aren't they I just wanna find a
green herb though see something through
there
Green huh [ __ ] I was was the go inside
yeah I figure they would be really bad
bullet sponges what is in the window
there that's creepy
stop
I haven't finished exploring I wanted to
knife that box I should have done all
this before choice ah
wait wet barrels by barrel right barrel
are you gonna do what I think you're
gonna do yeah [ __ ] die all of you I got
some gunpowder
what can I go in here now
Oh what the [ __ ] I'm just going into
toys plays but what the but okay cool
yes okay I love that I just you know
kaboom on the red barrel that's exactly
what happened okay any more red barrels
down here or like oh there's an electric
box sparking that's gotta do something
oh [ __ ] yes three shots three head shots
I don't know how long they're gonna be
like that for
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] sorry
I swear alot when I play these types of
games
ooh am I going oh I don't I
eleven nope get some donuts drug store
owners Journal the new hair tonic from
umbrella is just flying off the shelves
the stuff they make umbrella made hair
product what the stuff they make always
works wonders so it's no surprise I was
counting on this and all did a huge
shipment my instincts are playing off
literally
I just know sales will continue to rise
as we're gets out that said the string
of violent incidents on the news war has
worried me maybe I ought to invest in a
good safe hole to hold all this cash
Estonian the new safe is just perfect
nobody knows the code Oh tell me the
code this is like the easiest safe to
crack it's right next to the safe it's a
secret between me and my beautiful a
cure Queen what the bloody how oh okay
it's not it's not that easy yeah take it
back I take it back take it back okay I
can make some more bullets now wait hold
up
yes I know
here six Oh Frick I can't wait to play
this game like this week has been so
stressful why I just can't help but be
so happy that I have both animal
crossing and this game I feel blessed
and you guys of course oh [ __ ] off
I hope that's not another one in there
maybe I should stop aiming at the legs
again I learnt this last game why am i
defaulting back to head shots as I
played of the game since right oh oh
that's cool
well done level designers I like this
it's a creepy creepy creepy setup okay
he's [ __ ] coming after me isn't he
that's okay I don't think it's gonna
come this way famous last words
where are my prescriptions pharmacy
they're stain spray yay
[ __ ] you why do I mean look at me no I
[Music]
can't stream animal crossing I'm afraid
I don't have a capture card I was trying
to look into it I need a capture card or
an Xbox one and I don't have either
those things why do I not shoot the legs
and [ __ ] a duck you too he's to our
fleshy I'm not gonna Shane oh my god
just [ __ ] fall over you prick freeze
struggling there oh my god I wasted so
much bullets oh thank god
if I was actually in this situation I
would be awful I'm so loud
what we have
okay why the hell am i finding so much
ammo and gunpowder in the prescription
shop why aren't I finding any green
herbs okay red hair or um first-aid
spray that's what I've wanted from this
place and went missing something
come on we're in a pharmacy damn it okay
well I guess I can't complain too much
I've got got bullets aqua queen who is
the aqua queen I don't know if I want
that code boom baby
yes I love that I love that red barrels
so simple so simple but so effective
where should we go I feel like we should
go up that way
uh-huh
but I still I just want something for my
health I can mix these two together and
get shotgun ammo but there's no point
because I don't have a shotgun
please don't wake up
please don't wake up
oh my god I've got freaking knife out
Jesus oh no oh no oh no oh no he's he's
freaking out oh yes where did he come
oh this is gonna help my situations Oh
money out of stuff so savory or anything
around here that would be lovely right
about now
planets getting worse and worse these
past few days
got a shotguns for when it hits a
breaking point looking it up in the gun
rack that should keep it safe from any
would-be looters while I go out and try
to find some more shells if things go
south cut the chain and bust out that
sucker I pray we all make it out alive
I can't carry anything if I can't
pirated they I need to find
this sucks
wait
okay I'll just come back later hopefully
I'll find another save room or something
oh pretty plans must be the subway
company's offices these days the same
room
in the event of a power outage the
subway will automatically cease
operations once powers been restored
please use the control panel to confirm
the situation's of which the train will
stop as well as which track segments
will be used okay this are the
situation's of stations if the route
ended it's unsafe and error will occur
nothing
okay
dumb it I'm gonna save room
okay let's go get ourselves some donuts
oh wait today worry I already caught
myself donuts I think oh I thought it
was three headshots
oh my god
hmm I don't have anything for this
no we haven't got some to us yeah you're
gonna treat ourselves
wait can I combine like now cool I
didn't know I could do that I thought
you had to for some reason I thought you
had to equip it like get it in somewhere
and then combine it
[Music]
this is cool
as soon as I get that
oh [ __ ] no okay
I was really expecting them to wake up
oh [ __ ] no I didn't look at the back
look in the back I love exploring and
looking at everything it saves me so
much it's oh my gosh that was a that was
intense
yes yes yes yeah I did
okay oh and I got these for cutting down
that that chain back there okay so how
am i doing am i okay thank you okay
oh dude how do I just open this up
without I'm actually fine which is weird
I didn't think I'd be fine okay um well
I don't need my shotgun shells
marzu here then I want to find something
to store what am I talking about
oh yeah I want to find another pocket
thing I feel like I should keep the fire
hose with me though should I should I
keep all of this tonight
wait can I save I didn't save oh yes a
demo I don't think I can save okay cool
so it's not really a sick wait nope
where is it where where where where he
be
yeah [ __ ] I'm cornered okay let's have a
look at our map I mean this was the lot
with a chain door I don't know this
place all just goes back around on
itself isn't it
what you mean don't run away from him
Bruno you trying to get me killed that's
all I can do how's the game so far in
tents Oh No
see I told you Owens wimpy death I don't
want to go outside
Berta's like face hey just close your
eyes and everything will be fine mm-hmm
all right should we just make a run for
it
[ __ ] ducks go go go go go go go oh my
god he's caught it's the last of us I
don't know fun cuz I protect oh my god
I'm actually getting rekt what the hell
[ __ ]
don't tell me after stuffing the very
beginning I don't want death I'm doing
okay thank God
okay this time this time we're gonna be
prepared okay guys this time I'm not
gonna go towards the door I'm gonna go
this way
ha ha beautiful ah oh I didn't realize
there was nice music here before because
I'd already been stupid and open the
door if I ever get a shotgun that would
be very nice okay we're gonna go back
not gonna go towards that door let me go
back here we're going to oh you're gonna
open this
a power line again oh [ __ ]
why me posta me behind me oh my god this
is why you guys are here though isn't
that really what the [ __ ] I don't even
want it I want the actual gun not the
frickin shells
oh my god oh that was so close just way
too close for comfort
I'm actually annoyed
why did I do that whatever doesn't
matter where did he come from
oh ah what's this this is where I came
from
what's this oh hello oh well you know
what ah beautiful oh now I'm just
actually use them all on you oh boy hit
you in the heart he went down with one
shot that's that's rare okay so anything
that I want to put back can I use these
here
oh okay no look like that would have
come off just by shooting it I already
like I like to save room music is it's
like that moment of calm to breathe like
how the bloody how am I supposed to do
this
[ __ ] off to that Kevin wait tonight did
I forget to take Oh shite I'm good time
again what do I do here where do I go
what is my purpose in life
so many questions [ __ ] I actually don't
know what I'm doing
I need to use my [ __ ] grenade does
she not do it automatically anymore like
she used to but that used to be so
[ __ ] helpful how do I get it out I
don't know I've got to quickly go this
and then go this and then go this and
then wait for it wait for it
[ __ ] you I can't survive in this
environment
oh [ __ ] oh yeah why am I going here
is this the way I'm Swiss I don't think
this is the way I'm supposed to get oh
my God thank God I got it I got Oh life
is good again
guys what the hell am i doing oh the
hose and the fire run or rips - you run
before but I was okay this I could do
this can I roll
no this that's I'm used to roll I can do
this okay huh
this stressful game
oh she was like I'm actually gonna take
out white yeah I don't need this
alright [ __ ] you I'm back she's back
guess who's back hey just doesn't
[ __ ] work guess who's back back back
back again again get miss some shells
shells shells I'm a dick dick dick oh my
god oh my god oh my god how the [ __ ]
guys like this is actually impossible
like what the hell where's this flaming
flaming thing of flames
oh my thumb hurts because I'm pushing it
down to run right
Franny the bolt-cutters
stars what that's the end you gonna be
so stressed out oh my god this I'm gonna
have to really just like up my game this
is gonna be so freaking hard you can't
with mr. X you could at least run away
he's not that fast he doesn't jump in
front of you
he doesn't freakin shoot some rope at
you and then just uh oh my god that was
so good it was so stressful it was so
scary and some really good tense moments
oh the shadow on the wall when you could
see the zombie eating the person perfect
risen evil moment right there brought
back to life ah yeah so he's mr. x times
10 he well he is indestructible
you can't kill him or hurt him but he's
not slow anymore he's fast and he got
skills
like he knows when you're about to dodge
him and he'll he'll get you and oh my
gosh yeah what there's a trailer after
this well well well okay let's watch the
trailer guys
thanks Wesker quick sell mega scams you
get it's free with unreal get realistic
environments
like John
[Music]
somebody who's capable of getting me the
hell out of here
[Music]
don't need Kenda you're all right you're
all right stretch
stop and do what I got you back no that
have to you better hide sorry
so creepy so cool
stars I'm glad that he's up at the end
of the game as well because I was
waiting for that in the trailers and he
didn't really study he kind of said it
but it was very weird oh wait no I don't
want to I should have said no ah okay so
that's the trailer looks spooky a spooky
even in the feel I've got to run away
I've got to get away from the pity of
driving to the heart of me love for sure
seems secure nowhere cuz I've lost my
leg but I toss and turn I can't sleep at
night once I ran to you now over from
you this Tainted Love you've given I
give you all I can give you take my
tears and that's not nearly all
[Music]
now I know Moe I've got to run away I've
got to get away you don't really want
any love from me you beat things right
you need someone to hold it tight and
you think love is play baby I'm sorry I
don't play about away 170 now I run for
you this Tainted Love you've given I
give you all account can I give you take
my tears and that's not nearly all love
don't touch me sainted love I can't
stand the way you tease me not love you
know you're happy so so I'm gonna pack
my things and go then it love you got
that then get away
ah don't you think it's a touchy baby
get away it's like you get so give it
some attitude um anyway and I I'm going
to say goodbye now cuz I need to have
dinner and then play Animal Crossing and
just love my life so thanks again for
watching me can't wait to for you again
next week probably will be
probably Thursday but I will let you
know on Twitter or dis cords have lovely
Tara evening enjoy your weekend trying
to have a chill one treat yourself this
weekend you deserve it
okay cool and don't forget to check in
with your friends and family okay have a
dear evening bye